bryan cranston has been out stories to
fill a whole book but the craziest stuff
that brian has ever done in his life
actually happened way before he became
the emmy-winning star Breaking Bad and
he took me through it all starting with
this mesmerizing fact you have also been
a hypnotist yes I have I could say yes I
have Nancy oh it's a little scary that
is a little scary Wow do you better be
careful those people those people had
act with you better be really careful
yes before making it as an actor he was
a farmhand a security guard a dating
consultant who matched up couples and
even a licensed minister how many
marriages did you perform I've performed
probably a dozen or so wow so you could
actually perform a marriage if you
wanted to today uh yeah it's still legal
and I can't help but wonder if at some
point there's someone watching Breaking
Bad and wondering oh my god I think
Walter White married us honey he met his
wife Robin back in 1986 on the set of
the old TV series airwolf his romantic
proposal was in a bathtub and he hid the
ring on his foot she turned I kissed and
I went oh um here and I just lifted all
my foot and then she had the tasty hold
it on yeah cuz I couldn't reach it she
had to pull the ring off might might oh
it's it's a tradition I'm hoping that
other people follow that that line of
proposal but he has also experienced a
lot of pain when he was a kid his father
a journeyman actor abandoned the family
Brian spoke about his new memoir a life
in parts at the live talks la event and
told me one of his most terrifying
experiences was with a troubled
ex-girlfriend she acted insanely and
threatened to kill me or to have me
killed and I had this epiphany I saw
myself hurt her killer no imagination oh
I was so real that I didn't know was my
imaginary
why until I found myself shaking on my
floor and sweating and realizing this is
what I've come to one of the most
disturbing times I've ever had you said
you actually channeled this a little bit
when when playing Walter White if it is
useful than anything and being able to
draw from your own personal experiences
yeah you pull that out in in this case
use it for something artistic and
creative as opposed to dangerous
you